[MUSIC PLAYING]
NELLY PORTER: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
I understand that there's
huge competition here.
It is lunch time.
So we really appreciate
your determination.
So this session is going
to be about shielded VMs.
And I am the product manager.
My name is Nelly Porter.
And with me, is going
to present or co-present
a little bit later,
Andy Honig, who
is software developer
manager for the teams that
develop shielded VMs.
So this topic is going to
be going a little deeper
than everything that
you heard about.
Together with Andy, we
will try to give you
a little more information about
what shielded VMs are all about
and what they are
trying to do for you.
The first and foremost for every
security talks that I've been,
there needs to be a slide
about our attackers.
So we decided to not
deviate this rule
and put some things
that will scare you.
So first and foremost, I think
you all believe and agree
with us that definitely
attackers are
becoming much more advanced.
And that's really why we need to
ensure that we have protections
against advanced threat.
And attackers are
usually going after data,
your data, your user's
data, your resources,
trying to DDoS you,
or maybe trying
to do what they're
supposed to do
and trying to exfiltrate
the most important secrets
that you have.
Also, sometimes, or
all the time, I guess,
attackers are trying
to get credentials.
And credentials will
help them to get
your VM and your
resources and use them
in whatever they need to do.
And those credentials really
need to be really well guarded.
So what we've seen so
far is that to guard
your data, to guard your
secrets is not trivial task.
And it's more and more difficult
as attack [INAUDIBLE] becoming
more and more comprehensive.
And now attackers also very
much understand cloud and cloud
scale and cloud automation.
So what we've seen in--
one of the reports that
we published last year
demonstrated that if any
VM started to be available
online literally in 4.6
minutes, plus minus,
this VM will receive
first SSH attempt.
And again, preferably, if
it's not really well protected
it can be compromised.
Also any resources
or any credentials
that will be exfiltrated
will be used literally
in a few minutes.
So they know how
to do their craft
and it's really why we need
to ensure that we are ready
for that.
You probably all agree that
security-- good security--
comes from the layers.
There is no, again,
defense in depth.
It's very common things
that everybody understood.
And that's really
why we actually
started to harden our systems
starting from the bottom,
from the lowest level we can go.
And you probably heard
enough today about Titan.
But we will repeat again why and
what Titan is providing for us.
So Titan is a security
chip that Google designed
and Google developed.
And these Titan
security chips help
us to provide very
important security controls
for our infrastructure.
So the first one that will
be applicable to this talk
is machine identity.
And machine identity
is done by the virtue
of how we manufacture Titan.
When we manufacture Titan,
the first things that we do,
we have set of keys that
we infuse in the Titan.
They burn it into the fuses
so they are not extractable.
We harvest those keys
in our registry and also
its Titan registry.
And we issue certificates, 509
certificates, to those Titans.
And now what
happened, those Titans
can be challenged or asserted.
And they can explain or
cryptographically prove
that they have
possession of these keys,
those Titan identity keys.
So now imagine that you put
this key on the motherboard
or network card,
and this motherboard
you put in the server.
Now this server can actually
cryptographically prove
that this server is belong
to Google in standing
in the right data center
and provide any capabilities
that we expect from servers.
So we called it
machine identity.
This second very
important property
and control that Titan's
offered to us is secure boot.
So secure boot,
again, probably it's
well known, standard concept.
You probably know about that.
Otherwise you will not
come to our presentation.
But secure boot is the idea
that every single binary
in your boot sequence
needs to be signed
by appropriate authority.
And if it will figure out
that something is not signed,
we will stop your boot and
boot of our system as well.
Also, again, the interesting
thing with secure boot,
we are trying to
provide the highest
security with our secure boot.
And what we call
this capability,
it's called first
instruction integrity.
And despite of long name,
it means very simple thing.
It means before you
execute anything,
let's ensure that it was not
tampered with or modified.
And that's what we
do with our firmware.
So Titan, when you
power up your server,
is actually validating
their own firmware.
It's not trusting
itself blindly.
And after that,
it's trying to help
to validate the firmware
of the machine itself.
It does it because it has
very important two properties.
First of all, strategic
location-- location, location,
location.
And what Titan is, it's sitting
in between the flash that
has this firmware and
platform controller hub that's
actually reading this firmware.
And the second interesting
property that Titan has,
it can keep your CPU at reset.
And it means every
single beat that PCH
is reading from the flash
is going through the Titan.
Titan validated, and only
after validation is complete,
it removes CPU from
reset, releases it.
And now CPU can execute
these instructions.
So this capability we called
first instruction integrity.
And the last one, measure boot.
And measure boot is idea
that compared to secure boot,
it will provide much
more detailed information
about what is happening
during boot sequence.
And measure boot in
our server machines
ensures that kernel
binaries that we're
putting on top of our firmware
and our boot loader is not
tampered with or not modified.
Why I'm talking
about that today?
Because as you can imagine,
after we laid down our kernel
and validated our hypervisor
KVM, now we start it again.
What I mean by that, now you
bring your compute resources.
And now when we started
your VM, the whole cycle
started from beginning.
We need to have your
firmware running.
We need to ensure that
boot loader is here.
We need to run the OS, the
boot sequence, and kernel.
And all of that has to
be somehow validated.
And today, until shielded
VM showed up, it was not.
So customers ask me--
I'm a product manager--
very many times if in my VM,
somebody compromised my VM
and installed some
backdoor, how do I know.
And being very frank with you,
you have no idea, literally.
So we want to help you to
find this very advance threat.
And from attackers'
perspective, they
want to compromise your VM.
They want to install malware
and all other boot level
and rootkit, the malware that's
actually incredibly dangerous.
And the reason why
it's dangerous,
because it presides
below, beneath your OS.
And when you're
starting your OS,
you actually have no idea
what is happening below you.
And also these
threats are usually
persistent between the boots.
It means it's has
very long lived cycle
and also they are undetectable.
So from our customers'
perspective,
they want to starve those VMs,
those tampered VM from running,
figure out what is happening,
update them, page them,
help them, and after
that, reestablish
trust with those VMs.
And also, very importantly,
all secrets on those VMs
need to be locked to those
VMs or to the environment.
And it's very important reason,
because the passwords, also
anything of value, is
usually global secret.
And it's software
barrier secret.
And it means when attacker will
exfiltrate it from single VM,
it can apply it through lateral
move to every VM that you have.
And it's a really,
really bad idea.
So what and how we
can help with this--
and it's [INAUDIBLE]
yesterday not today,
we introduced public
beta of shielded VMs.
And shielded VMs
is a product that
helps to protect against
those advanced threats
on your compute resource level.
We want to provide, and we're
providing, verifiable integrity
and exfiltration resistance.
And we offer it configured by
default, enabled by default,
and free of charge.
So the questions that I'm
receiving every single time,
if it's so great thing, why not?
And the answer
is, please use it.
It's actually a lot of value
for you, for our customers.
So what can you do with that?
Let me explain to
you a little more.
So we enabled on your VM, we
replace your old and rusty BIOS
or your master boot record,
and replaced it with unified
extended firmware interfaces.
Firmware, it's wonderful.
It's very extensible.
We're trying to not make
it super extensible.
But a few extensions
are very important.
And this extension
is secure boot.
So we're enabling
secure boot, similarly
to what we have in
our infrastructure
for your VM for a
specific subset of Google
curated images.
In addition to that, before
I will go any farther--
in addition to that, we enabled
virtual trusted platform
module.
It's a very long name but
it's crypto engine that's
very similar to our Titan.
But it's virtual device.
It's software that every
VM will have their own.
And VTPMs, or Virtual
Trusted Platform Modules
can do your crypto outside
of boundary of your VM.
It means any vulnerability
of your kernel or user
mode in your VM will
not touch, will not
change your
cryptographic operation
that VTPM perform for you.
And VTPMs are actually
the normal crypto engine.
It can generate the keys.
It can protect the keys.
And it can test the keys that
are coming from this VTPMs.
And Andy will talk,
again, in details
about what VTPMs can do.
But one of the most
important features
that our customers
like about VTPMs,
now they don't need
to trust blindly VMs.
Their VMs, they can
actually challenge, exactly
as we challenge machines.
And they can say, VTPM, prove
to me that you're actually
part of this VM.
And what's happening with
VTPM and its standard,
again, TCG, Trusted
Computing Groups [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's absolutely standard CPM
2.0 interface that we enabled.
We're becoming TPM
vendors as well.
So TPM pass all compliant tests.
So TPMs have very
interesting capabilities.
They have this master key.
It's called endorsement key.
And we are using our Google
CA to issue certificate
to those keys.
And these keys are actually
the most important thing
because then the VTPM can
attest if [INAUDIBLE]..
So if you will challenge your
VM and say, OK, give me your--
again proves that
I have this VM.
In addition to the cryptographic
attestation and signature,
we're giving you
triple information.
And that's very
important information.
It's instance ID, it's the
project ID, and the zone.
And then you have cryptographic
proof that it's the VMs
that you are really talking to.
There is no way for
anybody to change it
because it's tamper evident
log that we provide to you
as our attestation statement.
And that's what we call
strong VM identity.
Based on that, you
can decide if you
trust this VM to
share your secrets
or you are not
trusting it very much.
The second thing
that we enabled,
in addition to secure
boot, is measure boot,
very similarly to what we have
in our infrastructure level.
But in addition to what
measure boot's expected to do,
utilizing this VTPM
and measuring integrity
of every single binary that
we use in our boot sequence
and providing much more
detailed information.
For example, because how
this particular measurement
is created, every single
binary, before it's
executed in your pass,
is hashed and added
to the previous hash of
all other binaries that
have already been hashed.
And when you're going
through all of these cycles,
by the end of the day
you will have this hash
that you can compare
with baseline.
And we're creating this
baseline for your first time
ever that we are running
and starting this VM.
And [INAUDIBLE] runtime
calculated attestation
is different from
our baseline, we're
sending all of this
information to you.
So you can take actions.
Finally, you will not be blind.
And if anything will change
during this period of time,
we're sending this information
into Stackdriver notification
and alarms and all
other functions.
You can decide, stop
immediately this VM.
Literally stop, I need to
extract it and go with forensic
to figure out what is up.
Because out of thousands
of those VMs, one of them,
integrity failed.
Not a good idea.
But if you know that
this change is expected,
absolutely legit, you
updated something,
you added kernel driver,
you've done something
that you understand, you have
a way to rebuild this baseline
and start measuring integrity
of your boot sequence and kernel
based on this new
baseline that you trusted.
It's actually very
important when
you need to re-establish
your trust with this VM.
If VM was compromised
and you patched it,
the question is how
to re-establish trust,
how to continue to
trust this machine.
And we're providing
you with that.
And verifiable integrity,
you can actually see that
and understand and take action.
And VTPMs have very good
opportunity to actually
seal and protect your keys.
And Andy will be talking about
this in much more details.
Let me show you a quick demo.
And this demo is
live, as you can see.
So everything can be impossible.
So we're going to
Google Cloud Console.
And as usual, you will start
off creating your instance VM.
Nothing super, again,
different here.
You will give the
name of this VM.
So we right now at beta,
so this wonderful checkbox
is unchecked.
It means you have both options.
You can select shielded VM
option and nonshielded VM
option for every single
OS that we support.
We shielded multiple
OSes, as you can see.
And you select it.
Nothing fancy here.
So you will notice that we
added for this release--
sorry, let me try it again.
Let's go to full,
change it, show images,
lets me pick shielded
VMs this time.
And, as you can see
in security tab now,
all of these capabilities
actually checked in.
So now you have
reconfigured secure boot.
You have VTPM enabled.
And you have
integrity monitoring
that's also available.
We make it such
that you would be
able to opt out from
these if you will decides
that you don't need some
of these capabilities
or some backward compatibility
issue you will discover.
So you're absolutely in control.
But we highly recommend
that you will not touch it.
And then create.
And you have shielded
VM up and running.
But usually, our customers
do not create VM by VM by VM.
They need thousands.
They need really
massive production.
So for that, it's
usually using templates.
So let me show you how
easy it is to create
a template for shielded VM.
Let's pick Windows
for this purpose.
And again, exactly the
same experience you have.
You can opt out from
some of the capabilities.
Click Create, you have
shielded VM instance template.
And all that you need
to do, the next step,
is create a group
cluster of the VMs.
And again, after I will
put this wonderful name,
you can specify the instance
that you're going with.
And it's the instance
that we created
literally a few seconds ago.
So from this moment, I have
this from one to 10 VMs
that I can create after
I will click Create.
If I need from 100 to
1,000, I can set it up.
And it will be autohealing,
autoscaling manage group of VMs
that you can, all of
them, use as shielded VMs.
It's all my demo.
And can we switch to
the slides, please?
Moving forward.
So we didn't forget about
separation of duties as well.
Because we believe it's
critically important that only
and only if you would be
able to modify shielded VM
configuration or enable,
disable integrity policy,
integrity functionality.
So we added two additional
custom permissions,
IAM permissions, that you
can add to custom roles.
And we also added these to
the [? default ?] roles,
where the two instance
Admin V1 and Secure Admin.
So if you don't like, again,
our decision on these IAM roles,
you're more than welcome
to create your custom roles
and go with it.
So what I want to sum up
for you is that shielded VMs
provide significant value.
Not because we created
it and we love it,
but we strongly believe
that it's actually something
that you can use and
take and benefit from.
It's actually reducing
the trusted, TCB trusted,
compute base,
something that you need
to [INAUDIBLE] for your
cryptographic operation.
It's also removing, again,
any vulnerability and threats
that can happen in your
VM for your crypto.
It doesn't have
performance implications.
Sorry, it doesn't.
Everybody couldn't believe
me, even my engineering team.
But it's actually is reality.
So it's very, very low latency.
We will say it's
kind of not equal.
It does support live
migration and live
patching that all our customers
believe have to be done.
And it's hardware independent.
We specifically
didn't [INAUDIBLE]
it as pass root to Titan because
otherwise your live migration
will be in trouble.
And it's tested and verifiable.
A few more words about
integrity monitorings.
So this integrity monitoring,
you can get your tamper-evident
logs because it's signed by
VTPMs in your Stackdriver.
You can monitor them.
You can assign actions on them,
and decide what you want to do.
So I have one
additional demo for you
to explain why
it's so important.
And it's more
recorded because it's
difficult to
reproduce the attack.
But we will try to,
again, manufacture for you
real attack.
Can we switch to
my laptop, please?
So let's go with video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So you're booting
from your new VM.
The boot sequence is as
you expect, kernel loaded,
everything is fine.
We calculated [INAUDIBLE].
We compared baseline.
And [INAUDIBLE] use it,
everything is wonderful.
So now if somebody will try
to boot from different boot
sequence, or even change
the sequence of binaries
when you boot, we
immediately will find it out
and provide for two feeds--
all information about
that and very basic
pass or fail indication of that.
[END PLAYBACK]
That's all.
So can be switch to
the slides, please?
And now, Andy Honig,
my partner in crime,
will continue this presentation.
ANDREW HONIG: Thanks, Nelly.
So I'm going to talk--
can everybody hear me?
So I'm to talk a little bit
more about the actual security
properties it provides
and how it works,
and get more into the details.
So I have up here the
server security model,
which is very, very vague.
But basically you've got
your operating system.
You have your VM.
And you're worried
about compromise.
You want to be able to detect
and minimize the damage
if you do get compromised.
And you do that with
a variety of tools.
You do it with anti-virus.
You've got audit logging.
You've got intrusion
detection, maybe
some other kind of monitoring.
There are things
on the operation
from privilege separation.
But if you're an
attacker and you
want to break into something
and stay in there long term,
you can lie to all these things.
Right?
So our threat model is your
attacker has broken in,
has root privileges on your VM.
So if someone has root
privileges on your VM,
can you really trust
any of these things
up here if you can't
trust the thing down here?
So that's really what
shielded VMs is about,
is making sure that once
you have this lower level
and you're certain that
this isn't compromised
and this is in good shape,
then you can actually
have some faith in the
higher level things
you have above that.
So let's talk about how
that works specifically.
So here's an example
of secure boot.
So secure boot's been
around a long time--
10 years, 20 years,
something like that.
And it's been around in
the real hardware world.
So in real hardware,
Microsoft mostly drove it.
And they got a key
baked into the firmware
for a lot of the
OEM hardware makers.
And that key is a public key.
And it's baked in.
And in the Google
case, we control it.
So we have our key.
And then the private
key is held by Microsoft
or the distribution
owners or [INAUDIBLE]..
Or in our case, we have a copy
for our container optimized
image.
And the people who make those
images sign those images.
So they have their own process
for keeping those keys secure.
They can have
those keys offline.
They can be a quorum of three or
five people to do the signing.
However secure they
want to keep those keys,
they can make those very secure.
So that public cryptokey
is baked into our firmware.
Then the boot loader is
signed by that private key.
When the Google controlled
firmware comes up,
the first thing
it's going to do is
it's going to check the
cryptographic signature
on that boot loader.
And if the signature does not
match or if it's been modified,
it won't boot.
Then the boot loader
then checks the signature
on the operating system.
It's up to the operating system
just how much to measure there.
Most of them measure of the
entire kernel and the drivers,
and if those don't
match as well.
So if an attacker
has gone in and he's
changed your kernel
drivers, which
is where you want
to change things
if you want to lie to all
of your intrusion detection
systems and monitoring
systems, then secure boot
will fail to boot.
So another thing that's
often confused with it,
but totally different,
is measured boot.
They go hand in hand.
Measure boot relies
on the virtual TPM.
Again, TPM is a standard
that's been around a long time.
As Nelly said, we are completely
compliant with the spec.
It's been around,
again, about 20 years.
So secure boot solves
a problem that says,
am I in a state that has been
signed by someone, yes or no.
And if yes, you can boot.
If no, no.
Measured boot tries to answer
the question of exactly what
state did I boot in.
And it tries to answer it in a
way so that after you've booted
you can ask and be
confident about the answer.
Because you can have a boot
log, Windows has a boot log,
Linux has a boot log, and you
can go and read that boot log.
But if someone's broken into
your kernel, how much trust can
you really put
into that boot log?
So TVMs have hardware mechanisms
called Platform Configuration
Registers, so PCRs, and
the property of those
is once you write to them,
they actually can't be zeroed.
They can only be extended.
So as the Google controlled
firmware is coming up,
it reads the boot loader
and extends that into a PCR.
Various other things like
the secure boot configuration
are put into that PCR.
And then the boot loader will
measure the operating system
and put that in the PCR along
with a variety of other things.
And what that provides you is
if you read those PCRs later,
and they match, you
can be absolutely
sure that has come up
in the configuration
that you expected.
If they don't match, you don't
know exactly what was wrong.
You have a hint because
there's different PCRs
for different things.
But if they do match, you
can be absolutely certain--
unless someone's
broken [INAUDIBLE],,
but that's not very likely--
that it came up in that state.
The other thing that VTPM has
is because the VTPM participates
in the cryptographic
protocol, it can remotely
prove that to somebody else.
So you can remotely
prove to another system
that your system came up in
a good and measured state.
And it was the right state.
And in our case, you can
do the remote attestation
with the VTPM or we
actually short circuit
that to make it easier
because we control the cloud
that you're running on top of
to deliver that straight to you
via Stackdriver, as she showed
in the integrity monitoring
demo.
So VTPMs, as Nelly
was saying, I've said,
they've been around a long
time so there's actually
quite a few use cases.
She talked about sort
of strong integrity.
She talked about
protecting secrets,
protecting
cryptographic secrets.
There's use cases around tamper
evident logging and quite
a few others.
I'm really just going to talk
about the binding and sealing
use case.
It's one of the
more popular ones.
It's used pretty
thoroughly in Windows.
There are some Linux
applications that use it.
Let's say you have a key.
And you need to hold onto
that key across reboots
because it encrypts something
or it saves something important.
And you want to keep it around.
But you don't want
to have it leaked.
So it seems like a
pretty common use case.
If someone compromises your
VM, reads all your files,
or something gets a
backup of your disk,
you don't want that key going
out, running around everywhere.
So that's kind of what the
binding use case is for.
So basically, you generate
your key or you take your key
and you tell a TPM,
bind to this TPM.
So it will encrypt
that key in such a way
that only the TPM
can decrypt it.
And because the TPM is
part of the hardware,
that means you have to be on
that machine and in our case
that virtual machine
to get that key back.
That's the binding use case.
If some backup
administrator, let's
say you have a backup
administrator who takes backup
of your systems, tries to
connect it to another VM
or tries to exfiltrate
that data in any other way,
your key is safe.
A little bit more advanced
is actually sealing.
So I talked about
measured boot and I
talked about how it will measure
the state of your system.
You can actually seal a
key to that measurement.
So what that means is
that you take your key,
the TPM will encrypt it.
And it will only
decrypt it later
if you booted in
the right state.
So if you got some kernel
rootkit in there and someone
has changed your OS system and
you try to get that key out,
that won't work.
This is one of the
major use cases.
This is how BitLocker works.
So BitLocker says, if you turn
off secure boot features that
are part of this measurement and
my system doesn't come up with
those features enabled, you
cannot recover your BitLocker
keys, for example.
If you were to take the entire
disk and move it somewhere else
and try to decrypt
it, you would fail
to do even though you got
the entire disk because
of the BitLocker key is exposed.
So now I'm going to hand
it over to Raphael and Mike
from Gemalto to talk about
some customer success stories.
[APPLAUSE]
RAPHAEL DE CORMIS: Thanks, Andy.
Thanks, Andy.
So at Gemalto, we are a
security company from France.
Maybe my accent told you that.
And we are historically
providing security
for SIM cards, payment
cards, or identity documents.
And we have long also
moved to services
in the cloud for our customers
around digital identity as well
as authentication services.
Moving to the cloud,
it's not an easy ride.
And it's a bit like
going to the fun park.
So to really enjoy it,
you have to make sure
that you can trust the
ride and all the partners
in the [INAUDIBLE].
So we do have solutions
to encrypt at rest
the data, to product
the data at rest,
to protect the data in transit.
And really, we wanted to
go further and protect it
while it's in use.
So as we are working with
Google on numerous topics
such as Android security,
machine learning,
we really accepted
the proposal of Nelly
to go further and see what
virtual TPM could provide us.
So why, really, should we
care about virtual TPM?
So the first one is
that you can have
your data being accessed while
being processed or in memory.
And we want that
to be protected.
Second is that you can have some
code which is not permission
being executed on your VM.
And that's not
something also you want.
And finally, you have some
code that can be modified
and which lead to bad execution
or to counterproductive measure
in your service
that you don't want.
So we did test, thanks to the
early access program, the VTPM
and the shielded VM.
And here is our very, let's
say, high level conclusions.
So first of all, as
Nelly and Andy shown,
it's a straightforward
configuration.
So it was really very easy
to upgrade our workloads
on our machines to be
sure that they would
be running using shielded OSes.
So second, we have
security teams in France.
So they played all along.
They tried every, let's say,
tricks that they would know
and really, every
time, we were not
able to stop any VM that was
attacked, either compromised
with a malware and rootkit,
either on the Linux
or on Windows.
And finally, most
important, is that it
has zero impact on
performance, and which
is really helping out especially
when scaling down or up.
So in term of usage, we see two.
So the first one is really
one related to certification,
meaning that for example on
the PCI DSS, which is a payment
certification that we
take for our customer,
there is some requirements
on the integrity
of the data on the software.
So this is really helping.
And second, we also have
some very sensitive workload
we want to protect, especially
around cryptography.
And that's what Mike
will present you
on all the very quick ways
we can get functions of VM.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE SCHROCK: So,
thanks, Raphael.
Appreciate it.
So I'm Mike Schrock.
I'm in business development.
And I kind of want to take
this talk towards more
and more practical expression.
And what we envision
and how we know
our customers are
using our products
and what they want
out of our products
when they move to clouds
in a more virtual world.
So Nelly, Andy, and
everybody talked
about how the underlying
infrastructure can
be highly secured now in new
ways with great attestation,
so the hypervisor, the VMs.
But in a shared
responsibility model
from a security
perspective, you guys also
have to architect up the stack.
Right?
So that becomes key management.
That becomes secret management.
It becomes DevOp security
policy, access controls,
and things like that.
So for 15, 20 years, Gemalto,
through our KeySecure product,
has been delivering
that on premise side.
Now we have a virtual
edition of KeySecure.
And we want to
make sure that that
gets deployed in the most
secure fashion on every cloud
out there.
And Google has offered
us an amazing ability
to do that with shielded VM.
And additionally,
that KeySecure,
whether its tied back to on
premise physical KeySecures
or its just running native up
in the cloud for your cloud
applications, it tends to also
need a client side encryption
component that sits on
the application level.
So to do tokenization of the
data, to do data encryption,
to do file level encryption,
to do database encryption,
there's oftentimes a
client connector component
to the key manager, using
[INAUDIBLE] to talk back
and forth in a secure fashion.
And so having both
the application
on a trusted OS, on a trusted
VM, on a trusted hypervisor
provides incredible
integrity to our solutions
for our customers, things
that they could rely on
in our hardened appliance back
in the physical data center.
And now they can essentially
rely on it the same.
We're excited about where this
is going and where it can go.
We're excited about
potentially getting
connections to external HSMs
out of our cloud service
or off the customer premise
back into the shielded VM
to be a rooted trust
or to be an encryption
key for the database that's
running in the key management.
We're excited about potentially
getting custom images being
signed also by Google.
So not just your
standard OSes, but have
custom images available too.
And we're excited also
about what Google platform
security has announced with the
silo and shielded containers.
So a silo is the secure
enclave open source project
that they announced a couple
weeks ago, a month ago.
And you can see where this
goes in the next iteration
of why not just run
that in a completely
shielded, secure enclave.
And so we're going to
continue to work to make sure
that our products are as
secure as possible for you guys
and that you can take and
bring your own security,
develop the same DevOp policies,
audits that you're doing
on premise in the cloud to
make it easy for compliance
and make it easy to drag and
drop as many applications
as you can on the Google Cloud.
So thanks.
And I think we'll
pass it back to Nelly
and take questions from you.
NELLY PORTER: And the final
words for all of you, so first
and foremost, Titan
is actually helping
us to establish
secure foundation
for every single workload
you're bringing to GCP.
We're extending this root of
trust, hardware root of trust
that we have from
Titan, to VTPMs
to your compute resources.
And we are absolutely
excited to ask you to start
using our shielded VMs.
It's in public beta.
It's available everywhere.
Our great
documentation, website,
everything ready for you.
So please, please, please
start using it, provide us
feedback, and we are ready to go
and take you to the next level.
[MUSIC PLAYING]